this is a carny house so these headshots
before we show them how did these
headshots happen personal I don't know
how you got them because I literally
thought I had the only two hard copy me
something with me I was like dear God
they're out there I had just moved to LA
I had only done theater in New York for
a very long time
and I got my first commercial agent
which was like above us like a sandwich
shop so he he told me that I had to get
character shots and it's usually I
always found them silly because it's
like do you really if you're gonna play
a cop do you really need to see a
picture of someone like it a cop Jessica
but I've been working at The Groundlings
theater and I was doing this weird
character of this woman who like gave
out cheese samples in a grocery store
and I was like I'll do Carole so you
know two weird characters like no one is
ever going to hire these one who's the
first one the first one here Oh God
- aw it's for casa
look like where you've upset you the
dolphin those dolphins yeah that's I am
26 in that picture and I thought it was
a great idea to put on a great sorrow
big and old lady glasses I'm like sure
we wouldn't hire her I think people
might hire her before this next woman
maybe like a full sweat my god
that is from western Barbie I took her
hat
and I took her boobs are hot it's a
cowboy hat from Harve you may be hearing
I'm a deer in that I had a craft project
I thought I was like a bit of ravioli in
your hand I need tiny cowboy hat on
elastic
an area in LA that's like a
predominantly gay area and I was there
getting hedge getting like picnic let's
kick some ass kick some ass who's number
one
we are who's number two who give the